state health leaders say they are
reviewing the cdc's new recommendations
but not commenting on them just yet
right now the majority of nevadans are
not fully vaccinated
the itunes vanessa murphy live in the
digital center with a closer look at
vaccination efforts vanessa
well so far the state is reporting that
close to nine percent of nevadans are
fully
vaccinated and about 16 percent have
started the process so far meaning
getting that
first dose and the state has that
information broken down here
on the covid 19 dashboard now some good
no
news here the state's allocation or the
amount nevada receives from the federal
government
is increasing and the state's covid19
task force reports that
eventually doctor's offices will be
receiving doses to administer but no
word on when
now this is week 13 of nevada's
vaccination efforts
those first doses arrived december 13th
during a virtual meeting with the
state's covid19 task force today
i asked candace mcdaniel who heads the
vaccination efforts
what have been the biggest challenges so
far
the volume the magnitude of really
trying to offer
a vaccination to every single adult in
the state
i think it has never been done before as
we know
and so you know i think that is
definitely the most difficult aspect
two major groups who the vaccine is not
yet available to
people with underlying conditions and
casino workers
still it is unclear when availability
will expand
to include those groups state health
officials aren't providing a timeline
right now i reached out to the southern
nevada health district
a spokeswoman says she doesn't have a
timeline to provide either
i know it's something many of our
viewers want to know we will stay on top
of this
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now